[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paris schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen für die fußball
nationalmannschaft läuft es bisher super
bei der wm quali
und wir schauen auf die wichtigen themen
heute
afghanistan angriff der taliban verbote
werden erlassen es gibt gewalt gegen
journalisten
200 ausländer dürfen ausreisen
unruhe in der union csu macht
kanzlerkandidat laschet für schlechte
umfragewerte verantwortlich
und einsatzbereit für den weltraum der
saarländer matthias maurer ist der
nächste deutsche der im herbst zur iss
fliegt
erstmals seit dem abzug der
internationalen truppen konnte heute ein
ziviler evakuierungs flug aus kabul
starten an bord 200 menschen mit
doppelter staatsbürgerschaft
afghanische frauenrechtlerin waren
jedoch die internationale gemeinschaft
die taliban seien nicht gemäßigter
geworden das innenministerium der
islamistischen übergangsregierung erließ
als erstes auch gleich ein protest
verbot bereits in den vergangenen tagen
hatten die islamisten demonstrationen
gewaltsam beendet reporter wurden
festgenommen teilweise misshandelt es
gibt berichte von angriffen gegen
demonstrierende frauen
menschenrechtsorganisationen fordern
regierungen weltweit auf gefährdete
afghaninnen und afghanen aufzunehmen tom
pollock berichtet sie können afghanistan
verlassen rund 200 menschen mit
doppelter staatsbürgerschaft haben von
den taliban die erlaubnis bekommen
auszureisen auch deutsche staatsbürger
sollen an bord seien von kabul aus geht
es nach doha in katar der flug in die
sicherheit um die sich andere die in
afghanistan bleiben müssen immer mehr
sorgen machen zwei afghanische
journalisten zeigen heute was es heißt
wenn die taliban brutal zuschlagen die
beiden männer wurden festgenommen und
misshandelt weil sie über eine
demonstration in kabul berichtet hatten
ungefähr zehn minuten lang schlugen und
sieben oder acht leute so viel sie
konnten sie hoben stöcke und schlugen
uns mit aller kraft nachdem sie uns
geschlagen hatten sahen sie dass wir
ohnmächtig geworden waren und brachten
uns in eine zelle mit ein paar anderen
protestgruppen werden es künftig noch
schwerer haben gleich mit seinem ersten
erlass fährt das neu besetzte
innenministerium einen harten kurs
demonstrationen ohne genehmigung sind ab
sofort verboten niemand solle versuchen
proteste zu organisieren
andernfalls drohen strafen immer mehr
greifen die taliban in den alltag von
frauen ein an universitäten sollen
vorhänge die studentinnen von den
studenten trennen sofern sie nicht
eigene räume bekommen mit den neuen
einschränkungen versuchen sie uns in
früherer jahrzehnte zurück zu versetzen
denn sie haben viele einschränkungen
eingeführt die nur für mädchen geld
auch bestimmte sportarten sind für
mädchen und frauen künftig verboten
mädchen brauchen keinen sport sagt der
vize chef der kulturkommission sie
würden sich im bloßen sagt er und dass
er im islam nicht erlaubt
frauenrechtlerinnen und die uno warnen
daher eindringlich die augen der welt
sind jetzt auf afghanistan gerichtet
aber sie werden es nicht für immer sein
es ist wichtig dass sich die
internationale gemeinschaft weiter für
die situation von frauen und mädchen im
land einsetzt und darauf aufmerksam
macht die achtung von menschenrechten
ein moderaterer kurs die taliban zeigen
immer mehr dass damit kaum zu rechnen
ist
in afghanistans nachbarland pakistan ist
für uns susanna sand ina susanna viele
menschen versuchen aus afghanistan zu
fliegen wie ist die situation an der
afghanisch-pakistanischen grenze
also im moment ist die lage relativ
entspannt sie war aber auch schon sehr
dramatisch in den letzten tagen und
wochen zum beispiel am ersten september
in der nähe von ketter westlich des
landes als tausende flüchtlinge versucht
haben die grenze zu stürmen und die
pakistanische armee mit schüssen
geantwortet hat eine ähnliche situation
gab es vor kurzem auch in der nähe von
peshawar wurden drei afghanische frauen
von sicherheitskräften getötet insgesamt
ist es ja so dass pakistan in den
letzten jahrzehnten zwischen drei und
vier millionen afghanische flüchtlinge
aufgenommen hat und die regierung ist
der ansicht dass nun andere länder die
verantwortung übernehmen müssten nämlich
so heißt es diejenigen die in den
letzten 20 jahren in afghanistan das
sagen gehabt hätten was übrigens
auffällig ist dass viele dieser
flüchtlinge die seit jahrzehnten hier in
pakistan leben immer noch in
flüchtlingslagern entlang der grenze
untergebracht sind oder sie werden gar
nicht in die städte gelassen und ich
denke das zeigt deutlich welche haltung
die pakistanische regierung zu diesen
flüchtlingen hat vielen dank für diese
einschätzung susanna santino
und das interview haben wir vor zwei
stunden aufgezeichnet
wir blicken nach deutschland hier wächst
der druck auf armin laschet den
kanzlerkandidaten der union in umfragen
zur bundestagswahl hinter der spd kommen
jetzt ungewöhnlich deutliche worte aus
münchen einen tag vor dem parteitag der
csu die letzte chance für einen
stimmungsumschwung so csu-chef söder sei
an diesem wochenende und sein
generalsekretär blume sieht die schwäche
der union begründet im kandidaten
wirklich natürlich stünden wir mit
markus söder besser da
theo koll aus unserem hauptstadtstudio
geschlossenheit sieht anders aus was
verspricht sich die csu von dieser
kritik an laschet
aus bayerischer sicht wird damit heute
ja sehr deutlich gemacht dass die sünden
dort kein herdentier ist sondern
vielmehr ein im rheinland ansässiger
einzelgänger namens armin laschet es
sind schon erstaunliche absetzbewegungen
vom eigenen kanzlerkandidaten und das
zweieinhalb wochen vor der wahl auch der
csu-landesgruppenchef
alexander dobrindt hat sich heute mit
einer art messlatte zu wort gemeldet
laschet müsse seine persönlichkeitswerte
deutlich verbessern als ob das mal so
eben ging insgesamt wird er vom
triumvirat der csu erheblicher druck
aufgebaut verknüpft mit einer art
vorformulierte schuldzuweisung söder sei
eben besser gewesen das zielt
offensichtlich auch auf den morgen
beginnenden csu-parteitag und die sorge
dass die christsozialen bei der wahl
unter die symbolisch wichtige
fünf-prozent-hürde rutschen könnten und
möglicherweise nicht mehr alle
direktmandate in bayern holen insgesamt
ist es eine schwierige gratwanderung
zwischen aufrütteln einerseits und sich
absetzen dankeschön theo koll und armin
laschet ist gleich bei uns im programm
um 20.15 stellte sich fragen der bürger
innen klartext herr laschet
razzien heute im bundesfinanz sowie im
bundesjustizministerium die
staatsanwaltschaft osnabrück ermittelt
gegen die geldwäsche zentralstelle des
zolls der sogenannten fau wird
vorgeworfen hinweise von banken zur
geldwäsche nicht an polizei und justiz
weitergeleitet zu haben bei der
durchsuchung der ministerien ging es um
die kommunikation mit der fa you und
auch um die frage inwieweit
verantwortlichen ministerien
entscheidungen der geldwäsche stelle mit
eingebunden waren
hacker angriffe auf deutsche politiker
und politikerinnen gab es schon mehrmals
in diesem jahr der bundestagswahl dabei
ging es wohl um den versuch persönliche
daten abzugreifen
wegen des verdachts der
geheimdienstlichen agententätigkeit
ermittelt deshalb jetzt der
generalbundesanwalt die behörde vermutet
russland hinter den angriffen moskau
wies die vorwürfe als kampagne zurück
die pandemie hat in deutschland viele
kinder und jugendliche krank gemacht
gerade essstörungen haben zugenommen so
der kinder und jugend report der
krankenkasse dak so wurden 2020 in den
krankenhäusern 60 prozent mehr mädchen
und jungen wegen übergewicht behandelt
als im vorjahr bulimie und magersucht
namen und fast 10 prozent zu und wir
schauen auf die entwicklung der korona
zahlen die sieben tage incidents ist
wieder leicht gestiegen auf 83,5
innerhalb eines tages haben sich erneut
15 1431 mit dem virus infiziert 606
menschen kamen neu mit symptomen im haus
damit steigt die sogenannte
hospitalisierung rate auf 1,89 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner
sieben jahre war die deutsche botschaft
wegen des bürgerkrieges in libyen
geschlossen heute wurde sie durch
bundesaußenminister maß offiziell wieder
eröffnet die botschaft ist in einem
ehemaligen fünf sterne hotel
untergebracht auch den niederlande und
italien haben dort ihre diplomatischen
vertretungen
maas sprach von einem neuen kapitel der
deutsch jüdischen beziehungen seit dem
vergangenen jahr geht in libyen eine
waffenruhe
zwischen fluten verheerende waldbrände
die klimakrise bedroht nicht nur
menschenleben sie kostet auch milliarden
von euro darauf weist eine neue studie
von greenpeace dem deutschen institut
für wirtschaftsforschung und der
londoner universität sowas hin
greenpeace demonstrierte deshalb heute
mit einer ice kultur vor der
europäischen zentralbank auch die
geldpolitik müsse sich künftig an
klimazielen ausrichten fordern die
studienautorinnen
und nun zu einem wichtigen urteil für
sie als verbraucher innen und zwar geht
es um kreditverträge beispielsweise beim
autokauf häufig hinter die klauseln
kompliziert und wenig transparent das
müssen kreditunternehmen nun ändern
urteilte heute der europäische
gerichtshof passiert das nicht hat man
auch noch nach jahren die möglichkeit
kreditverträge zu widerrufen auch nach
der 14-tägigen widerrufsfrist die
details jetzt von birgit franke
ähnlich wie die kläger beim ogh hat kein
möglich sich 2016 einen vw passat bei
einem händler gekauft und diesen über
die vw bank finanziert er ist zwei jahre
später widerruft der freiberufler den
kreditvertrag grund er sei fehlerhaft er
will den wagen zurückgeben
ich habe widerrufen weil ich der meinung
bin dass das nicht ganz korrekt war und
das zweite ist natürlich dass ich mir
auch einen gewissen finanziellen vorteil
davon erhoffe der ogh bestätigt heute
die klagen der autobesitzer das einen
vertrag auch nach jahren widerrufen
werden kann wenn pflichtangaben nicht
klar und verständlich sind zum beispiel
muss die höhe der verzugszinsen exakt
momentan 4,12 prozent punkte angegeben
werden die beklagte vw bank dazu wir
erwarten aber nicht dass zahlreiche
kunden den widerruf erklären werden der
bgh hat bereits klargestellt dass der
kunde im falle des widerrufs
vollständigen wert ersatz schuldet wie
der wert ersatz genau berechnet wird ist
unter juristen umstritten
rechtsexperte christoph herrmann meint
aber dass es sich für viele lohnen kann
zu widerrufen auch für verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher mit anderen
kreditverträgen
das urteil ist für den verbraucherschutz
in deutschland ein gewaltiger schritt es
korrigiert die bisher eher verbraucher
zuletzt eher verbraucherunfreundliche
rechtsprechung des bundesgerichtshofs
zum kredit widerruf und eröffnet ganz
vielen kreditnehmern einen ausweg aus
entweder notleidenden krediten oder aus
kreditverträgen die ware finanziert
haben mit der verbraucher jetzt nicht
mehr zufrieden sind stiftung warentest
mit zügig an den rechnern zum ermitteln
des wertersatzes online stellen und
noch eine entscheidung diesmal vom
bundesgerichtshof zeigen influenza innen
in sozialen netzwerken ein produkt ist
das nicht automatisch schleichwerbung
ein werbehinweis muss aber gemacht
werden wenn von unternehmen geld fließt
so die richter in den verfahren ging es
um die beiträge von drei influenza
hinauf instagram die darin auf produkte
hinwiesen und
vom cyberspace kommen wir zum out of
space also dem weltraum dort dann
startet nämlich in knapp sieben wochen
der deutsche astronaut matthias maurer
als zwölfter deutscher wird im auftrag
der esa ins all fliegen auf die
internationale raumstation iss mit an
bord viele wissenschaftliche aufträge
und kartoffel riesling suppe aus seiner
saarländischen heimat trainer gerrit und
susanne freitag
es ist einer seiner letzten termine in
europa vor dem flug zur internationalen
raumstation zur stunde bekommt matthias
maurer gemeinsam mit seinem
französischen kollegen thoma pesci den
großen deutsch französischen medienpreis
verliehen schon im all
mission startet ende oktober
wir zeigen dort oben die europäische
flagge europäische präsenz und das ist
ganz wichtig weil der raumfahrt wird
heute immer internationaler raumfahrt
verbindet die nationen raumfahrt ist
aber auch nur machbar wenn man starke
partner hat fünf jahre hat er sich
vorbereitet forschungs und
überlebenstraining unterwasser übungen
im 200 kilo schweren raumanzug er wird
über 100 wissenschaftliche experimente
im weltall durchführen gemeinsam mit
kolleginnen und kollegen aus russland
den usa kanada japan europa auf
politischer ebene gibt es da natürlich
kontrahenten aber in der raumfahrt sind
wir gute kollegen und wir verlassen uns
aufeinander ich hoffe zum beispiel auf
einen weltraum außeneinsatz zusammen mit
russischen kollegen und wenn ich dann
aussteigen aus dem raumschiff und bin
nur mit einem menschen dort draußen und
dieser kollege ist nur dann ist das mein
allerbester freundin diesem moment im
saarländischen oberthal hatte sich schon
vor ein paar tagen verabschiedet hier
kommt der her er freut sich auf den
moment wenn er die heimat von oben sieht
ich denke das wird dann schon ein
besonderer moment sein wo man denkt okay
da unten komme ich her und aus dieser
perspektive ist das mittel europa und
ein paar minuten später ist man dann
schon wieder über asien das ist er der
blick aus der ss ein halbes jahr wird
matthias maurer ihn genießen können so
lang wird er im all bleiben
und wenn sie noch mehr missen wollen
über den deutschen nächsten astronauten
zum beispiel wie er für den weltraum
packt ein ausführliches interview mit
matthias maurer gibt es in unserer zdf
heute
frankreich verneigt sich vor einer
legende 1000 menschen nahmen heute
abschied von jean paul belmondo im
ehrenhof des pariser invaliden doms
versammelten sich regierungsmitglieder
prominente und die familie präsident
marco würdigte bei mondo als
ausnahmekünstler wir haben bei mondo
geliebt weil er uns ähnlich war sagte
marko der schauspieler war am montag im
alter von 88 jahren gestorben
und wir kommen zum fußball norbert läuft
gerade
das kann man wohl sagen drittes spiel
dritter sieg in der wm-qualifikation so
wie geplant das einzig ungeplante war
die zwischenlandung des dfb-teams in der
nacht im büro die maschine hatte
technische probleme zuvor alles
problemlos beim 14 0 gegen island in
reykjavik ein traum start unter dem
neuen bundestrainer in drei spielen 12
tore kein gegentreffer hansi flick ist
es in kürzester zeit gelungen dass die
dfb-auswahl wieder modernen fußball
spielt alles läuft nach plan wenn man
jetzt so die drei spiele nimmt dann
können wir sehr zufrieden sein mit der
entwicklung bei einem spielfreudigen und
treffsicheren team gibt es aber auch
noch steigerungspotenzial
wo wir uns verbessern müssen noch ist
einfach auch in der präzision im letzten
pass
in der entschlossenheit ein starker
anfang ist gemacht aber die ganz grossen
herausforderungen kommen erst noch
und nochmal fußball japan verzichtet
wegen der korona pandemie auf die
ausrichtung der für ende dezember
geplanten klub wm der weltfußballverband
fifa sucht nun nach einem neuen
gastgeber
weitere deutsche erfolge bei der
straßenrad-wm in trient olympia siegerin
lisa brennauer holte im einzel
zeitfahren bronze und zuvor hatte hanna
ludwig bei den u23 frauen silber
gewonnen gold ging an die überlegene
italiener vittorio azimi die 39 sekunden
schneller war und
zu den us open in new york hat tennis
olympiasieger alexanders wäre seine
erfolgsserie fortgesetzt und das
halbfinale erreicht durch den 7 zu 6 6 3
und 6 4 sieg gegen den südafrikaner laut
harris nur nach einem wutausbruch seines
gegners gegen alexander zverev kurz zu
boden als der weltranglisten vierte
mithalf den vorübergehenden
wasserschaden zu beseitigen nach dem
engen ersten satz kam der hamburger
besser in die partie gewann den zweiten
souverän
es wäre auch im dritten satz mit einem
frühen break spielte zeitweise überlegen
mit seinem 21 es verwandelte er seinen
ersten matchball
wie bei olympia in tokio ist sein gegner
im halbfinale am freitag die nummer eins
der welt novak djokovic
das wars vom sport vielen dank und für
morgen kündigen sich neue gewitter an wo
genau erfahren sie gleich von ist
intelli christian sievers begrüßt sie
hier um 21 45 zum heute journal auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannt das thema beim wetter für
die nächsten tage sind schauer und
gewitter und die gibt es in der
kommenden nacht aber auch morgen die
kaltfront des tiefs bei den britischen
inseln kommt morgen im tagesverlauf
voran und löst dann teils kräftige
gewitter mit starkregen aus im osten
deutschlands wird es noch mal warm mit
warmluft aus dem süden in der nacht gibt
es schauer vor allem im westen und
anfangs auch noch gewitter die lassen
allmählich nach im osten lockert es auf
genau so vor allem im südosten dort
temperaturen bis 10 grad im westen ganz
im westen 18 grad morgen im tagesverlauf
also neue schauer und gewitter von
westen her mit der kaltfront und später
auch im osten einige gewitter und das
bei höchsten temperaturen dort bis 27
grad ganz im westen werden 20 grad
erreicht aber häufig werte deutlich über
der 20 grad marke in den nächsten tagen
gibt es noch schauer und gewitter vor
allem am samstag das ganze zieht
allmählich ab temperaturen bis 24 grad
die temperatur in der nächsten tage
bleiben ähnlich und einzelne chance noch
dabei montag um 25 grad und trocken ein
schon amt